[Music]
looking for some late summer fun las
vegas now's jc fernandez heads to lake
mead to show us the sport of tubing in
this week's vegas drives
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
swimming in the lake is a great way to
cool off but so is tubing on lake mead
and that's what we're going to do today
with our good friend bruce nelson bruce
it's always great to see you buddy yeah
it was great to see you thanks for
coming out again all right so tubing
okay let's talk about tubing what is it
do you guys rent the tube and someone's
watching they want to go tubing so yeah
you can't really rent two but you can
buy one you like start from you know 40
or 50 dollars up to a few hundred or
more depending on what you want to do
and it's just a great everybody can do
it you know grandma and grandpa the kids
mom and dad everybody can too that's the
great thing about your squad have a good
time um you need a boat you need a
couple people you need some life jackets
a ski flag and go have a good time tube
number one what is it we got just a
basic tube
for one guy or gal the the joby revolve
one now the rules out there if i want
you to go faster or go slower any hand
signals i should have went out there in
the world you know you want to go faster
thumbs up slower thumbs down you want to
stop you know all right you ready
here we go get it
[Music]
there he goes outside the way finally
after
oh he's done that's the workout man
yeah you did good that time how fast are
we going oh we're doing what like 30 30.
yeah about 30 about 30 30. i feel like i
was doing 75. are those bathrooms
floating bathrooms oh is that what we're
towing next uh yeah we'll just put you
right here
thank you they're actually already went
i'm good so no i'm kidding i want to
know is that we're doing that thing
that's our that's our next ride that's
the uh we'll call it the cone the cone
how many people does the code for and
we're just gonna drag that thing behind
the boat drag that cone standing up yeah
okay four people one
two
lands here number three a photographer
and the fourth guy will be our spotter
yeah in the boat in the boat yeah how do
i get on this thing i just just jump and
hold on man
that didn't work racing
my turn
now you okay here we go on the other
side
we made it
that was not easy i'm exhausted just
from getting on
this isn't going to go well
water sports don't like me
let's go okay
oh my god
that's
we're still on we're still on
that one
all right here we go here we go
all right next
step off
wow we gotta hand it to our cameraman
lance props
yeah he's doing everything there